okay so we are here for another round of
language completeness and consistency we
haven't been knowing as many live
streams recently because we are both
rushing to get put into 0.1 done and I'm
off working on my big physics project
which hopefully I will start doing live
streams about soon we've been doing what
might be called dead streams recording
all kinds of things but it doesn't make
a lot of sense until the whole project
is released so that will hopefully
happen fairly soon all right
let's go and start looking at this um
and various topics here structured array
documentation you know I have to say
structured arrays have not had as much
of a day in the Sun as I might have
hoped can we explain that
well I think it's been a resource issue
that we didn't have somebody working on
it and then he flaked and you know yeah
but I mean but but do we care I mean in
other words have structure to raise
whether I assume Rob is here right yes
I'm here um I mean structure raised just
haven't I haven't you like I haven't
used them ever well we only have two at
the moment so that's what are they
the cemetery's array in quantity array
what quantity right has its own head
I'll do all structure raised that's why
we need to update the documentation so
this is part of the discussion so we
implemented quantity array in the
framework of a structure array which is
there waiting to add many more types of
structured arrays so you wanted to have
quantity array to be its own head and
now in 412 to we are planning to that
also data rate which is continues this
framework so this change is to make
these objects to have their own head
following also sponsoring what I mean
their own head well maybe if you look at
some of the examples then quantity array
right the full form right the full form
of this used to be structured array of
blah blah blah with a quantity array
inside of it now the full form of that
is quantity array of you know various
stuff so if I look at this on I say full
form yeah okay right and the same thing
for symmetrized array and I mean we have
a few more structured arrays sort of
implemented but they're not fully
polished so we haven't documented so
basically structured array is becoming a
subterranean creature
I mean there's nothing now no place
where you do structured array on its own
as a head is that correct right
except for legacy compatibility so if
you get one of the old objects in it
we'll evaluate to the new full form does
anybody know what the relationship
between these things is and data
structures in the compiler like it's not
tries to write I could see being related
well I think there's really no no
relationship because the data structures
I mean these these are things that that
basically provide alternative
representations for lists of things now
there is you know there are some of
these data structures
what like dynamic array that provides an
alternative representation list but it
has special you know this special
feature
well someone tries to write it sounds
like it's a special you know feature of
a list well-known it's not a special
feature of a list it's a special
representation of a list that happens to
be very compact for things with lots of
symmetries just like sparse array
happens to be very compact for things
with lots of zeros in them personally
okay from what you're saying here what
is the point here what you want to do is
to make structured array what is what
does it currently talk about on the
structure rate page isn't it like
selling structured arrays as their own
thing yes yes I this is a I that's part
of the reason why we made this change is
cuz this it's better to be like sparse
array and and stuff and half though well
there was a plan originally to have a
whole collection of you know vandeman
matrices and God knows what else or all
kinds of different kinds of structured
arrays you know I am right right we came
of that plan well the the the people
we've had to to work on that have been I
mean we had a person who was working on
it and then he left and
another person who became very flaky and
basically disappeared for months at a
time okay okay all right fine but that
isn't an answer to why we gave up or are
we giving up because what you're
proposing to do is to give up on the
vision of structural array and I mean
that was Roger's vision so he should
probably be the one represents I mean
this might it was my vision originally
is of having this thing a structured
array and and we thought about it you
know I thought about it I thought about
some of the the input Jose had had you
know with quantity R and stuff and and I
don't think this changes the vision at
all it just maybe you should also open
up structured array head cute it just
means we might call you know well I eat
your eyes so few tries but if you it's
there's a link right there in structure
okay this is getting very quickly in my
opinion no I don't agree with this I'm
sorry I just don't agree with this I
think this is in the nature of kind of
advisory look this this reminds me by
the time you have something like this
okay that's it that's an internal
discovery question and it's like is this
error message really an important error
message or is it just a warning it's it
becomes a much more complicated issue i
what do you mean right I mean you you
need right so structured array is is now
a token then what is the role referred
generically the only role of this is to
determine whether normal common
structured array will will you know will
eat this particular thing otherwise
you're just looking at head of the thing
and then you look it up in the
documentation and you say is it an
example of a structured array I'm just
not I'm sorry that this really isn't
working for me I kind of agree with you
Stephen I mean I take sure this needs to
be a when I when we document structured
array as a token that can refer to all
structured arrays
how do you document that I don't know
what that token is really for and that's
that so maybe you should look at some of
the examples I understand I understand I
understand I understand what I do and I
was saying that in advisedly okay I do
understand what it's for
as in its its to deal with the allowed
head stuff and the normal stuff and so
on right it's to banks which a bunch of
functionality well you don't want to say
oh I don't want to I mean the fact is
you know you've got a quantity right
before you but you know not necessarily
I mean right if you're writing in
generic code what reactionary code code
that accepts arbitrary arrays and you
want to sort of you have sort of code
for lists and then you know a generic
case for can I ask a question what
feature these things that are of array
type they accept certain kinds of list
operations like part extraction and so
on correct yep that's correct okay so
this is essentially the statement I am a
structured array means that I accept
what set of operations
well that's somewhat dependent right I
mean there's a baseline of you know part
and normal Oh what about determinants
for example if I'm a sparse array I'll
accept determinants if I miss if I'm a
symmetrized array I'll accept
determinants I hope if I'm a quantity
array I don't know whether I accept
determinants well any festered array if
if there isn't a dedicated algorithm for
it will normalize and then evaluate that
way in in sort of the thing in the sort
of generic matrix e array operations
world well the answer Stephen is is
basically you can do you can do just
about things like arithmetic you know
operations like transpose matrix
operations things like that work what
you can't you the one thing you can't
use these for and this is the same
sparser a is you can't use sparse array
as like a list argument to something
like integrate like you know x comma you
know limits on integrate
that's a you know that in a sense we
might call it a symbolic wrapper list as
opposed to a data list of some kind yep
that's that's that's perfectly
reasonable and that's that's basically
the distinction okay but so a
symmetrized array I could feel them with
wild abandon to the machine learning
functions true or not true depends on
whether they you know if they wrote
their code properly yes
I wonder if QA has tested that okay that
we could find that out but but okay look
right so so Stephen let me tell you what
what we're trying so first of all we
need to update the the structured array
page period right because it's becoming
vestigial basically yes well it's not
completely vestigial because we do use
it and we and we I strongly argue that
we need to continue to use it why argue
against I've argued this time and time
again the thing we want for allowed
heads is not to have something like
structured array we want a setting for
allowed heads to allow all things of
this type of list see I think that the
allowed heads thing I think this is
gonna be a story and you attacked my
analogy but I don't think it's a wrong
analogy I think we you know in our error
handling thing we are going to need this
mechanism to say if it's just a warning
ignore it otherwise abort for example
now somebody's warning is another
person's red alert and I think similarly
here somebody's oh it's close enough to
being an array that I should just bucket
it in with the arrays is okay and other
people it's not
and I think it's gonna be a somewhat
arbitrary dividing line and I think the
right way to handle that is with a
string setting for loud heads it is a
bit arbitrary and where you really have
to you know it's it's a do the right
thing kind of thing and if you want to
be sure that it's really really doing
the right thing you write out the head
explicitly yeah that's that's that's
that's what I've been saying all along
with this loud heads we need a string
that means everything that kind of
represents represents a list right which
is right which is its list or sparse
array or structured array right or is
this representation for example or you
know some some simple name right and I
wasn't suggesting that as the name I was
suggesting that as the right I think
that example if we have infinite lists
or cyclic lists so for example is an
association list like enough to be
something that you wanted you know do
whatever you're doing to or not see I
think it's a slippery slope I think it
says there isn't a bright line and
that's why I think it should be handle I
think okay look I think we are going to
need a sort of a calculus of these
dividing lines between is it a warning
is it an error is it a list like thing
is it not a list like thing in other
words it's like well well we have we
have we have a pretty bright line about
list like right is it a list
representation or not and we even have a
function developer backtick list
representation okay that I didn't know
that but okay is that a data list or
could that be a symbolic wrapper list so
for example let's imagine that we
introduced the thing one day called
infinite list symbolic list is that a
list or is it not a list array certainly
not it's certainly not a rake you used
with lists itself well I wonder about
that it can be used with list operations
like part extraction take things like
yes but what would normal of that be I
cannot give a list if it's an infinite
list
well yes that's true unfortunately
that's our basic idea here that the
structure arrays and like is press erase
under normal you're giving a criterion
this is you are exactly making my point
okay you were giving a criterion that is
can it be normalized to a regular list
right that is a criterion but it is not
the only criterion another criterion
that for some other purpose I might want
is can I do part extraction on it or can
i compute its you know which is actually
what dimensions and array depth
currently do right I mean this is why
array depth is of sine of 1 is 2 that's
crazy and weird or or I guess one rather
than 0 right which is why why does it do
that because it's looking at their head
right because the the top level head can
be arbitrary the the default setting of
allowed heads is in is essentially an
inherited other than the fact that lists
can be sort of okay listen I I think I
strongly think the right answer to this
is it should be part of our project of
making these bucketing things you know
errors versus warnings list like this is
not very list like you know there's a
whole bunch of these distinctions that I
mean it's an interesting thing
okay so let's muse on this for just a
second ok you know we have a language
that has very precise characteristics we
also have Wolfram Alpha which is a pure
do what you do what I mean
type system right this dividing line of
like is it an error or is it not an
error is it these are sort of meta
language constructs and I think we don't
really have you know I think this is
sort of a new frontier is how do we
handle you know
how do we handle sort of the heuristics
I mean okay another place where we have
this is in syntax coloring and code
assistance that's a sort of another
place but but in that case there's
always a human in the loop
um the um see what's interesting here um
you know yeah I mean what's interesting
is in syntax coloring there's a human
right there in the loop so whatever the
Machine does in its advisory capacity
the human gets to decide what to do a
warning or an error for example there
isn't really a human in the loop because
the machine is just kind of run and do
stuff yeah interesting I mean anyway I
don't know does anybody have any
particular comments well well I still
have two comments that are one I mean we
can't link the structured array page as
is as it's just wrong let's look at it
and we well we should clearly what's
wrong about it it's just it everything
almost everything right I mean all the
stuff about symmetric I mean what
happened to the asymmetric cyclic what
happened to all these arrays with I
thought we had a whole calculus of
Riemann tensor and things here you can
have multiple signatures there yeah that
wouldn't so what else
excess but that's not that's not a
structured array that's a symmetrized
array and the symmetrize to a page is
more or less fine
hey I have a totally irrelevant question
I have it totally totally monumentally
around my question and I apologize for
asking but I could ask it anyway
what's that I'll prejudge you if you
look at square root of G
the volume elements in general eternity
I'm asking this because I know that
people here who who am and you expand it
you know you look at G of you know X
plus Delta X and you make that expansion
in Delta X the first order term is a
Ricci tensor right the next order term
is some whole zoo of Riemann tensor z--
what is the systematic expansion of the
nth term of that buttons was irrelevant
but I'm I thought somebody here might
know I had I would have to think I mean
I've been I've been looking it up and it
doesn't seem it seems like people make a
big deal out of computing the nth term
and it doesn't seem like there's a
formal version of what it is I think
this must be a property in some special
coordinate systems like normal
coordinates I because you can use
arbitrary coordinates I don't think
that's a property that scaffolding any
coordinate system
so what problem wait wait really because
I mean I was just gonna ask is it if
it's really a Ricci tensor for the first
derivative or isn't it the Einstein
tensor no it's a Ricci tensor it doesn't
it doesn't it isn't traceless okay I
mean the usual formula I'll pull up for
you on the square this is actually a
paper by Alfred gray if you remember is
unfortunately dead now but but he was
has this big book on differential
geometry with with Mathematica fine
fellow he got it he got he got
introduced to our product because he won
it in a raffle
in 1988 anyway he has this formula here
this is this is some but he's looking at
the volume of a geodesic ball this is
the this is formula which is the thing I
probably most care about that's the
formula for the volume of a geodesic
ball and this this thing here
Oh Oh what is that that that's the sorry
that's a volleyball that's the that's
the Ricci scalar scalar and then right
but actually I was I was looking at the
thing where you're looking at the
general expansion of which is I think
more this thing here the general
expansion as you go away from a single
point you've got this one sixth of the
rij xixj then this whole zoo of horrible
mess right though you're in the northen
normal yeah that's a 14-day normal basis
around the point and so what is your
point your point is that with an
arbitrary coordinate system you're
saying yeah there's much less you can
say well this one is not going to hold
it will have terms that depend on their
Detroit choice of coordinates but what
is the purely formal symbolic version of
this thing independent of code is there
a coordinate independent version of this
might say no because the Delta X's and
coordinates right but I think the
argument speech has the opposite you fix
a coordinate system which is
particularly interesting like this one
or normal coordinate so something like
that and then you can derive a formula
which which will have yeah it's this
type of of expression now the
interesting thing here is that when you
start taking derivatives of Bremen there
are many terms that will be related and
this is a standard problem attractivity
how do you make sure that two terms that
are formed by products of derivatives of
Riemann's are different or equal and I
have technology to to handle this up to
certain or hmm okay I may be a consumer
this afternoon actually
that technology trying to understand
them I can get up to 12 derivatives of
the metric so that's my limit why
because this is this a serious that you
construct and it becomes combinatorially
more and more difficult so I just clean
it up up to some order
has like a million relations okay all
right all right fine so we came to the
right place
okay well I think that's some fair
enough fair enough
oh this is a more formal looking
expansion not as bigger mess well anyway
okay sorry that was that was definitely
off-topic but um okay I'm gonna ask you
another question here but but no this is
even more off-topic it's anybody who who
knows remembers enough about Renault's
Asian group applied to I'm trying to
compute a bunch of running masses and
running coupling constants and make sure
I actually get them right anybody
remember that stuff well I worked on it
40 years ago but I haven't worked on it
since I don't think I said well the main
thing I remember about that is that oh I
had a homework assignment to compute the
a two-week homework assignment which
consisted of one problem which was to
compute the one loop renormalization in
QED so now that that one I could
probably even still do the know I'm
interested in just that I mean the
renovation group equations that depend
on group weights and things and depend
on a bunch of stuff and I just wanted to
i probably there I'd been horrified I've
been because I've been relooking at
particle physics obviously I I lasted
particle physics before that long before
the web existed and I've been a little
bit upset to find out two things about
it number one that there's much less
about it than you would expect on the
web and number two that random things
that I made up when I did particle
physics have wound up becoming standard
things in without any attribution but
that was long lost by towers of review
papers and things but you know standard
utterly arbitrary choices of things I
believe it a trace to random things I
did long long ago and both of these
things I find quite shocking I mean that
there's so little about it
comparatively when it seemed like it was
the hottest field in the world anyway
it's it's a little disappointing to see
that makes one wonder what yeah anyway
no matter okay all right off off topic
but um but okay back to structure to
right so I mean okay what is happening
to all of its I want to be a riemann
tensor stories well that's that's where
we see that that's not a generic
structure right because the quantity
array is a structured array right it's
you know how that had right we haven't
really did the examples on that one
right that has head structured array if
you really ate that input you'll now see
the head symmetrized array which is also
true into full form and I mean if you
want to see the are unfinished other
structured arrays I think it's a
structured array backtick dollar
structured arrays is that the the symbol
Jose donor structure right heads
oh boy fine Devon matrix was in that
yeah clearly one of the earlier earliest
due ones based on it's it's you know
context so what do you imagine is going
to happen in the future
so in the future we'll have a block
diagonal matrix and a matrix product and
the permutation matrix just like we have
a quantity array in the symmetrized
array and you know they will obey
structured array head q and you'll be
able to write code that you know either
treats all structured or AIDS the same
or you know picks out a couple of them
and then sends all the other guys to
some generic path because right normally
what
have is you have a few efficient
algorithms for you know one or two of
these types depending on the operation
and the structure and then everybody
else right you need some generic code
all these other guys just normalize them
and use the generic slow path right that
sort of the problem you need to solve
I mean equally right we want you know
when we write so this is the this is the
old so we you that's the structure right
new which I think I had up here great
yeah it's that notebook right there
you're just not at the top at the moment
okay so yeah that we probably shouldn't
say transpose there because it doesn't
really work from transpose but like
array depth in look we're not ready for
this
I mean basically what you're trying to
do is to deprecate structured array and
here something which is important in my
opinion is that rob has created this
great framework to add the new structure
right types and I have started using it
for two cases that are a bit special
start symmetries array are is really a
structure a quantity array not so much
and data array not so much either so I
think with this change what we gain is
that we restore the symmetry with the
other types of arrays express our race
and numeric array and also something
important is that as we add more of
these types it was becoming more
difficult to do things for a given type
of array because they were all
identified by the head structure ring so
now users will be able to do something
like underscore quantity array and do
things on wanted array only turn is
great so to me adding this this new I
mean changing the framework to look like
this is it's a resource when okay so
look basically what's happening is we're
deprecating structure array
we need a mechanism we want a mechanism
to make lists like things that walk and
talk as lists to be normalized to be to
be able to be asked for a normal those
are the two known things that are
happening right now right so or or or in
things like dimensions you want to
restrict sort of all lists light thing
fine fine but I mean so we need awake
ism to do that and so so if we're going
to add a string value to allowed heads
are you know you know go ahead are you
okay with something like list arrays or
maybe that's maybe that's putting it the
wrong way
yeah um actually do your your name
Steven is not not not to me you do sort
of care crises is like data lists right
data look I think the string quotes
arrays might be okay I don't know no but
a raise already represents that yeah I
know I know
um representation let's we actually have
internal developer list representation
is it developer internal I'll say I can
never remember develop yeah I don't know
whether I'd understand if it said a loud
heads are a list representation that
seems very weird to me it's like mixing
parts of speech yeah um well what is it
list convertible allowed heads of things
which are convertible to lists I think
of a car with its roof down
um well we could go a little bit more
whimsical and we could say lists like
yes I was actually thinking less like
myself
somebody's gonna read that as list licky
dear me I think that's the least crazy I
think that's the one mode if people see
it they would know roughly what was
going on yeah okay you know what I think
we should do I don't know that we're
gonna do this for 12100 we're gonna wait
till later
yeah we've got a deprecated structure
too right
I don't think we're completely ready to
do that right now I think we it would be
a mistake to rush that I think that's
what we should plan to do well the thing
is we can't I mean for 12.1 we can't
easily go back on the changes I made to
not have like symmetrize to read good I
think those changes are great but what's
your point your point is we kind of need
to we need to change the structure Rea
documentation so it doesn't doesn't look
like it did before
why don't we just make it say the
destruction array is now obsolete and
it's being it's been you know spread out
into its into its some franchisees so to
speak put a stripe that just says
structure array is now being covered by
specific array types like someone tries
to Ray right I mean I mean I still think
it would be useful to have the
structured array token but maybe I mean
we had this this like thing I think we
shouldn't do it I think I think it's too
it's too slippery Neal
yeah so let's plan on a stripe here
and I mean some of this that's actually
nonsense should be removing will you
ever get a structured array as as output
for anything no you will get if you like
I said if you have a structured array
that you saved in a previous version
that has head structured array so we
could add a note saying that you know
for compatibility with legacy data you
know structured array of blah will
evaluate to that's what I would do and I
would rip out all of this stuff here but
it's all irrelevant and then just put a
stripe that's has been obsoleted okay
cuz I mean none of its examples will
work either so I mean it's just like a
pointless thing all right I think it's
good progress but I think come alright
fine and Rob do you think you can easily
add lists like yes yes yes let's try to
do that does that well because right now
I have to go through all these
contortions on the allowed heads
documentation about you know right
exactly I think that'll make that at all
much much easier yes soon I think I can
I can do that fairly quickly mm-hmm okay
I'm gonna skip the table generalization
again um I think it's because I think
those things here we really need to look
at uh random number generator so this
okay right I think this is good and
we're it's working in the prototype
build I mean I don't want you to defeat
rise it because I think we're too late
in the game to be adding a completely
new heads to okay fine
but I you know as long as you sign off
on this we can merge the pull request to
master and then the future dies once
twelve one is actually frozen you know
like the documentation is frozen is what
I mean
yeah it looks good to me okay
: random generator state yeah okay looks
fine to me okay random real of an
interval
right so this is some user suggestion
that I know somehow but what was past
bubble passed around until it ended up
in my queue so I'm looking at it I'm not
sure I'm not convinced it's a great
suggestion at least if all we're doing
is basically instead of saying random
reel of list a be you can say random
reel of interval of list
ap I mean the user could just take the
first of the interval and pass that in
well it's not so trivial if there's a
collection of intervals exactly that
would be for you know for Rob and where
we put that in the priority queue I mean
it shouldn't be hard you just turn it
into a random variate of a
multi-dimensional uniform distribution
why he can just take the total length
but then you have questions what if the
sub intervals overlap right do you
double yes so as far as the interval is
concerned it's only covering once yeah
so then only all you're doing here is
you you've smacked you take the total
length of the interval and you you know
you throw a random number in that and
then you divide it up into the end yeah
that'll work seems straightforward I
don't I don't think it's the highest
priority thing in the world but it seems
like a nice little feature at I think
it's useful to as a feature at I mean so
does that work right now with random
point random point of a random enter
watch interval 0 1 2 3 or whatever
but how do I do that it's a sequence of
lists
well you know let's let's try doing them
let's try doing see if we do yeah and
then we histogram it you're gonna need
to flatten it okay it's fairly
convincing all right well so that that's
how we should do it we should just
support random real get random real to
go around on point in that case any
objections no that's okay okay somebody
should put themselves on mute okay so
this is some place where I mean I think
I I guess I I don't disagree with the
motivation but I do disagree with some
of the details so so this is a proposal
of Constantine's who is here too should
be here yes he's here to speak for
himself okay right but the right the
basic idea is right right the file name
and sort of the range of bytes are
disjoint from each other because of you
know legacy and before we added format
and things like that so he's suggesting
we support a new syntax and I think but
I think we shouldn't yeah what's the
issue the issue is you want a hash only
like the header of the file or something
so you want to raise the issue is I want
to crash several files I mean that's one
of the issue here in each file you may
want to hash you know the first ten by
it's the last ten bytes whatever can you
open generate file signature page and
there in the built version I knew I hit
documentation the documentation
yeah so I just don't extend the syntax
to file rush
oh so you okay well I will argue that
you did this wrong then yeah I didn't
realize this was all alone you feel
correct except the second I think ah
but you said but you support the
singleton range here according the thing
which you said this shouldn't work is
documented to work on this page yeah I
miss I miss the second part so yeah
that's probably a bug yep I'm sorry
alright the section label proposal and
then you look at but range is presumably
a number there and files range it takes
better spend or new stuff right it's a
take spec so it could be one right it
could be 10 minus 10 300 through 500 etc
okay well we've already crossed that
bridge here by doing the ranges like
that and generate file signature on I
think this is a bit hokey and personally
I would prefer to see them as a second
argument and file in the file wrapper
[Music]
seems to me to package it better than to
just have it in a open list so to speak
right but I mean the file is supposed to
just be sort of a semantic tag this
thing is a file now you're adding
arguments to it which might be sensible
to some but not others I'm not sure
that's really what you mean you mean
that there are operations that say like
import and if you've got a bite range
specification and file you might think
that import would only import the range
bytes which would be a reasonable thing
to do in other words which might or
might not be a reasonable thing to do
yes quite
[Music]
so alright but fire hashing is a
sufficiently generic operation you say
that that you can always just deal with
the range of bytes right because all it
does is you know arithmetic on bytes or
maybe sequences of bytes but I wish we
had developed bytearray a bit further
but anyway okay okay so what's the
proposal here right so I was told to
have a new syntax for flesh and crawl up
the syntax for generate file signature
yeah yeah and phase out the great
bye-bye little commitment what is the
format option I see I see so you're
proposing then to move the format to the
third argument I mean it is I'm we can
unambiguously do that it'll matter that
works both ways seems okay to me
right I mean my me if you open the
disagreement which I guess Constantine
sort of now agrees with me but I will
point out the possible weakness of this
is right so if you have a list which is
a pair of filename and takes back then
you should get so it's a little bit
unstable right I mean you should be I
just missed this Portugal ah so I don't
understand what happened here what
happened what's the difference between
these two I took out one level of Lists
so I can see that but I mean why does
that make a difference isn't that just
saying a file a single file with minus
one you know with a single bite at the
end right in treats it as the list of
file names and so minus one is not a
string so it can't be a file name
right so so why don't we just in that
particular case which is what you're
proposing support file comma range yeah
if that's an integer yeah yeah or or a
take spectrum yeah yeah just I just miss
this case yep yeah ask question does
byte array have a take mechanism no I
would like to country I don't think so
so would it be take itself or no it has
to be a byte array take I would imagine
well no if we have streaming we've
overwritten part so I don't see why we
are you sure that take this up where I
may not not quite not for wasn't working
before I think it works but I I'm not
willing to stake my reputation on that
[Music]
well that's documented anywhere
we should check okay me we can hunt it
down oh okay good
all right fine seems okay to me okay
yeah
all right so this is a sort of a bit of
a thorny issue with with sort of a
time-dependent history you know but
basically is an empty list an empty list
of keys a sorry empty list of rules or
an empty list of associations so the
present time lookup treats an empty list
is an empty list of rules he drop and he
take treated as an empty list of
associations but until 11.3 ki-taek
actually treated it as an empty list of
rules so and they're sort of good
arguments in both directions so I you
know you can so the rules case it would
give a no list the list of associations
no no in in the in the rules case it
would give right it would give an empty
Essos well key drop and key take would
give empty associations and look up
would give missing like what is it I'm
sorry how does that look like a key drop
you're saying if I say key drop of a ro1
be ro2
doesn't it auto yeah it auto also
Associates of each mmm that's that's an
odd thing to begin with okay so then
what you're saying is that look up does
look up do the same thing well look up
only returns the one value hmm okay so
the same thing as the strange situation
that we had with nest while where it has
to return a nothing so to speak
right in the case where it didn't find
it what does it return no not really I
think this is more like the second
argument of replace when we have an
empty list is it a list of rules or an
empty list of list of roots or in
extract when we have an empty list is an
empty list
I mean position or an empty list of
positions right and if you open up the
two arguments sections you'll see a we
make that that point explicitly right so
my second bullet point is there are if
you treat it as rules were being
consistent with replace whereas if we
treated as a empty list of associations
then we're being consistent with extract
what do you mean an empty list of
associations you mean an empty
Association no I mean an empty list of
associations so right because you can
give a look at the right you can right
so in so right now right so if it were
treated as an empty list of associations
it would give an empty list because it
would look up the key from zero things
and therefore it gives an implicit
whereas right now it's giving you a
missing because it's looking up the key
from no rules and therefore not finding
I got it I kept you and you know this is
not the knot this is not the first time
this has come up there was maybe we
should have linked to it but there was a
thread that maybe a year and a half ago
an L kernel okay so here's my test let's
imagine pieces of code that have sort of
edge cases that are these things let's
see what they look like okay I think
that's what we have to think about and
then how did they recover what is their
error recovery in other words if it's if
it's a lookup I think it's what we have
to do I mean I I'm gonna guess that this
is a reasonable thing to do for look up
because I'm gonna guess that that is oh
boy people are using it as an el cheapo
Association or duplicate entry
Association
right I mean I think I guess I I
shouldn't I had Devon sort of written
this down but yes making a change I
certainly don't think we're going to
make the change for 12-1 because God
only knows what we'll break if we make
this change right there there's
certainly right if you don't know we
absolutely cannot do that and so well
look I suggest examining some code for
where this comes up and how people put
wrappers around lookup and key drop and
so on
to handle this case I mean clearly we
could imagine an option lookup for what
to do with this case or something I
think it's what we have to do because I
don't think we get answer this in the
abstract I don't see I can see arguments
both ways then hey we've got a couple of
questions on our live stream and got one
from Steve about for byte array often
wished a convenient way and the
suggestions bar to view the byte array
as an encoded string that's interesting
how would you a view it as an encoded
string I guess I'm not sure what he
means as an encoded string and well I
mean that we got a byte array and the
question is how do you I guess as base64
base64 they actually saying base 58 or
hex okay right so how would you actually
do that how would you view it as base 58
how do you feel attacks well that will
be based s-- encode of the binary comma
16 that that probably works in the
prototype build if you have the
prototype build but I can't guarantee
that there but there's an open pool
request we actually I actually had a
question about that which you know I
didn't think we'd get too
so I didn't put it here but which is uh
that's an interesting problem in
prototype built that was fun
okay go ahead let's just try this so I
tore a range of a hundred base in code
okay so I guess it's not actually in the
prototype build but that that will be
working in twelve to the main question
is about okay well I'm sorry but back
looping back to the suggestion so the
point that Steve on the live stream is
making is that it will be good in the
suggestions bar when you get out a a
byte array answer like a hex string I
like like a like a you know a crypto key
that one of the suggestions in the
suggestions Barbie this basting code
thing mm-hmm seems eminently reasonable
to me come who how do we note down that
suggestion to make sure it gets acted on
once we have base encode I think it
should listen to me if somebody takes a
set to get to system okay
also Mohammed on the live stream is
asking about please add support for all
and span and extract why isn't all
supported and extract I thought it would
be it's not is it hard
yes other complicated cases yes I mean
we've been through all of this you've
forgotten but we have a design and and
now it's just waiting i guess i'm
konstantine to implement it but maybe
constantly were you even aware of that
yeah it's being prepared
my comment on this is use use part
instead it's a more effective function
anyway well that's not a reasonable
thing to say they should both be
full-featured I mean they're both useful
in their own way
here was another question from Mohammed
um let's see when trying to manage
he says it's off topic but let's look at
it anyway when trying to manage email
accounts from language the server has to
allow less secure app access I presume
it's the teal it's the TLS version or
something but well is it producing mail
connect or is it for doing something
else I'm not sure this is the wrong set
of people to ask again when it seems
like the right set of people and be more
specific in what what you're asking I
think cuz we quite understand yes so
Stephen yeah about basin code right so
actually I real I mean it's still not in
the prototype build but I realized we
actually called it a 16 base 64 and base
85 oh and they and the second argument
the second argument isn't just the
integer 6 I feel good okay fine but
there there was a question about that
because I didn't notice the the thing we
call base 85 is commonly called ASCII 85
and then other the thing that the people
who make the distinction between the two
base 85 spell a different standard which
is the Z modem standard ah there's a
blast from the past all that base 85 so
I'm wondering if we should call it ascii
85 rather than base 85 base 85 a ski
base 85 ascii and then base 85z modem
only seriously gonna put z modem in
there alright well we'll have to come up
with something else for it but okay but
what is the description
I mean the right I think that's the
right thing to do I mean I don't know
what base64 lines is I think the well I
don't think we're going to have that one
I think that was sort of a way of having
sort of a maximum length right so that I
see no so you have well I don't know
whether let's discuss it separately but
whether it should be basic if I've asked
you I think that makes more sense if
they're both base 85 then let's qualify
them mm-hmm um rather than and not have
one that's just called base 85 probably
because that's a formula for get people
getting confused um okay ah
Carla's asking to be nice to allow other
integer bases basically yes the reason
it's not allowing it is um that is
completely undefined I mean these things
are just totally random they pick out
random ASCII characters and things to
use to represent bigger numbers is that
not correct yes I mean they're purely
conventional yes and each with the what
except for 16 which pretty much
everybody agrees although even there
there are sort of edge cases of like you
allow both uppercase and lowercase or
only uppercase and things like that so
right are in fact distinctions even
there but except for bay 16 where pretty
much everybody agrees on everything all
the other integer bases there are sort
of different alphabets and different
conventions about various things so okay
so Steve on our live stream is is
commenting on his use case for the base
encoding stuff as the demonstrates our
crypto stuff she says very compelling
and easy demo good we agree but he says
it's a snag when he gets to byte arrays
and there's a long duration to show
the key in in human readable form it's
an interesting problem the um right I
mean we figured that the key it's one of
these cases where who would ever want to
see the key isn't there a way of
converting it into a string how do you
convert it by terrain to us that's what
this is that's that's well no I mean I
think what he really wants is normal of
the bytearray
slash slash base for you know base form
of you know normal of the bytearray
sixteen right so that yeah I understand
with that and base form sixteen yeah and
probably two so that you you know comma
two uh you get how that doesn't seem to
be right does it even except that I
don't think that that would be
instituted it's oh right and that will
give you yet something different yeah so
yes it is a gyration right yeah oh
saying why not just allow an alphabet to
be given in base encode which is a
reasonable thing I'm just saying what to
do with each I mean that is a perfectly
reasonable thing to just say given this
number this is what you should do I
still still not complete I'm not sure
that's actually well-defined
I mean I'd have to think about it but
after top of my head that does not seem
well-defined right all right we should
wrap here um and uh yeah hey Hosea are
you around later I might need dogs and
Riemann tensor questions yes yes okay I
don't think I'm gonna need how many room
intensities did you say you could get up
to the database has all relations for up
to twelve derivatives of the metric and
because they and because the remand is
two derivatives of the metric
that means for example products of 6
remands or thin derivatives of a single
ring okay if we get to needing that I
will be very pleased okay all right
sounds good guys thanks thanks to folks
on the livestream we are almost up to
500 hours of live streaming here and
we're trying to figure out how we should
we should hit that maybe tomorrow we
like suggestions for how to celebrate
our 500 hours of live streaming maybe we
should do a I don't know what we could
do
we've got suggestions please please make
them okay great thanks a lot guys thanks
to folks on livestream - ok bye